[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec pour débuter
le déficit des nageurs sauveteurs au
bord des plages elle préoccupe depuis
quelques jours les départs de personnels
se sont accélérées depuis la crise
sanitaire reportage à suivre avec via
occitanie dès le début de ce journal un
canal vidéo une radio et un journal à
trois ce sont les détenus de la maison
d'arrêt qui découvrent les métiers de
l'information une initiative bienvenue
pour l'insertion que nous montrera la
rédaction de canal 32 sur place et puis
dans ce journal vous découvrirez celui
qui vient d'être élu le plus beau
village de la loire l'occasion d'une
visite guidée avec tl7 en fin de journal
nous serons en duplex avec tome benoît
philosophe l'auteur l'essayiste
spécialiste des questions d'urbanisme
vient de publier un nouvel ouvrage
aphorismes sur l' architecture nous en
parlerons avec lui
c'est l'une des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire le manque de personnel se fait
de plus en plus ressentir dans certains
secteurs restauration hôtellerie mais
aussi plus étonnant celui des nageurs
sauveteurs à quelques jours désormais du
début des grandes vacances la situation
inquiète les sapeurs pompiers chargés de
la surveillance des plages le métier
réclame de l'expérience bien sûr exemple
près de montpellier avec la rédaction de
vie occitanie un sujet signé linsee ou
hameaux
avec le thermomètre qui grimpe les
secouristes ont du pain sur la planche 1
agde on doit se tenir prêt à enfiler ses
palmes à tout moment tout en faisant de
la prévention va la faire qu'aujourd'hui
va faire très chaud donc il faut boire
beaucoup d'eau et m a lancé voilà ce
qu'on va faire plaisant pour informer et
moi on aura d'intervention et à
intervenir et moi y aura de problème ici
ils sont cinq à surveiller cette plage
la plupart sont de jeunes recrues suite
au départ de plusieurs secouristes ces
jeunes renforts pour cet été soulage
ismaël en poste depuis six ans mais
prochaine étape maintenant essayer de
fidéliser ses recrues car les caprices
de la méditerranée ne sont pas faciles à
lire il faut au moins deux rotations car
un effectif qui est expérimenté c'est
toujours un plus sur les plages donc
plus on arriva à fidéliser un petit peu
les les saisonniers sur les plages et
mieux ça sera pour qu'ils puissent
former aussi de nouveaux arrivants
objectif difficile à atteindre même si
les cv ne m'ont pas la plupart des
candidats ont souvent le même profil que
tu manqueras hier les 95% mort 4 10 %
d'étudiants et souvent ce qui se passe
ici en fin d'études et il trouve un
boulot pour entrer dans la vie active et
du coup le choix est vite fait ce qui
est normal d'accord donc du coup voilà
ce son désistement principalement pour
aller chercher du travail
perrin ce que l'on un travail saisonnier
une quinzaine de cv ont été reçus le 10
34 se prépare déjà aussi au recrutement
pour la saison prochaine
voilà harry cet été vous irait sûrement
à la plage pour vous rafraîchir lors des
fortes chaleurs pour ceux qui n'auront
pas cette chance les climatisations
ventilateurs et autres piscines
serviront peut-être de solutions à ce
propos la demande de ces produits
explose depuis quelques semaines avec
les coups de chaud constaté ces derniers
jours exemple en gironde avec ce sujet
d'alix fourcade de la rédaction de télé
7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
cet habitant de talence n'était pas
parti pour faire du shopping mais en
passant devant cette quincaillerie il
n'a pas pu résister j'en pouvais plus du
coupé g j'ai craqué j'ai voulu acheter
un vote schlatter voilà et ce n'est pas
le seul à avoir eu cet éclair de génie
comme le confirme ce qu'un cahier j'en
avais commandé 8 j'en ai vendu déjà 4 je
pense qu'à la fin de la semaine les huit
sont revendus heureusement le commerçant
avait anticipé la canicule on a commandé
un peu en avance parce que sinon mais
c'est déjà fait piéger et c'était un peu
trop tard
en revanche si vous souhaitez commander
votre propre piscine maintenant c'est
raté pour cet été en témoigne cette
vendeuse depuis la sortie du confinement
déjà et en plus depuis les fortes
chaleurs qui ont commencé déjà au mois
de mars on a reçu beaucoup de commandes
les gens ont vraiment anticiper tout ça
c'est à dire qu'au mois de mars avril on
a eu un pic énorme du taux de commandes
et là on est arrivé à un stade de
saturation on peut plus prendre du tout
de commandes supplémentaires parce que
on a plus de disponibilité et même pour
les clients qui ont déjà passé commande
il risque d'y avoir du retard dans les
livraisons à cause des fortes chaleurs
ça risque fin c'est compliqué sur le
chantier parce que tout ce qui est liner
membrane etc peuvent se détendre au
soleil donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
anticiper ça pendant des périodes de
bonnes températures il faut pas de plus
non plus donc c'est vrai que notre
planning est vraiment basée sur la météo
et en plus de ça et de la forte demande
c'est assez compliqué mais difficile de
se plaindre quand on sait qu'en nouvelle
aquitaine nous disposons de 720
kilomètres de côtes et pas de délai de
livraison prévue pour profiter de
l'océan à part peut-être quelques
bouchons sur les routes
l'émission face aux territoires été
diffusé jeudi dernier sur tv5 monde les
éditorialistes présents en plateau son
revenu sur l'actualité politique et les
conséquences des résultats des élections
législatives
regardez un extrait de l'émission avec
bruno cautrès et sylvain courage et le
résultat de ça c'est quoi c'est que la
france est vraiment ingouvernable de
fait on a l'impression qu'on est encore
un petit peu en 1788 toujours c'est à
dire que s'il faut trouver les voies de
d'instituer cette ce dialogue c'est une
discussion démocratique est on avec une
longue histoire de conflit en fait très
violent autour de ce coin alors on peut
espérer qu'enfin
on va le résoudre mais vu l'encombrement
comment on commence combat et il faut
dissoudre il faut que la dissolution
c'est un petit peu le divorce donc c'est
pas forcément des galops à petit la
faire tout de suite non non trop tôt et
il est évident que une dissolution
serait très coûteuse pour lui s'il un
cil et s'il a choisi trop tôt il faut il
faudrait que le pays soit vraiment
bloqué et qu'on puisse établir la
responsabilité de l'opposition dans ce
blocage
voilà l émission face au territoire et à
voir ou à revoir sur les sites internet
des partenaires de l'émission ouest
france nice matin 20 minutes et france
antilles le politique il est aussi
question dans l'édition du journal le
point consacré à la ville
d'aix-en-provence dans ce numéro spécial
l'hebdomadaire s'intéresse notamment à
la politique de l'environnement
mené par l'équipe municipale actuelle le
coup de chapeau sur le marché immobilier
local où la production d'hydrogène verts
sont aussi au sommaire de cette émission
spéciale du magazine le point cette
semaine
restons dans l'univers de l'information
pour nous arrêter à présent sur les
nombreuses initiatives de la maison
d'arrêt de trois établissements
pionniers en la matière permet aux
prisonniers de prendre part à des
projets de médias locaux un canal vidéo
une émission de radio où un journal
local les personnes détenues participe
ainsi à l'élaboration de ces
communications diffusé en interne une
démarche valorisante dans laquelle les
intéressés se sentent pleinement investi
un reportage loin des idées reçues de
canal ronde de la télévision de l'aube
la maison d'arrêt de troyes a lancé son
canal vidéo interne pour les détenus les
programmes diffusés sont sélectionnés
par les prisonniers en accord avec la
direction l' agence de production
fournit ensuite des films personnalisés
dans ce canal actuellement on retrouve
beaucoup d'informations des activités
mais aussi le infini qui expliquent le
greffe et à le film arrivants ça permet
d'identifier
les personnes et aussi les lieux et puis
il ya aussi un film déjà produit par
ailleurs que ce soit une fiction
documentaire qui est diffusée chaque
semaine malgré l'ancienneté du bâtiment
la maison d'arrêt à réaliser les
installations techniques nécessaires
pour la mise en place du canal vidéo
avec l'arrivée de ce dispositif un
nouveau poste a été créé pour un détenu
j'ai pu classer une personne détenue
supplémentaire au service général ce qui
permet de claix a créé un emploi donc
j'ai une personne détenue qui va
s'occuper d'alimenter de faire des
rubriques d'amener des connaissances des
textes des poèmes du slam je trouve ça
très intéressant d'en haut niveau de
l'aide que ça va apporter à tous les
arrivants puisqu'il y aura des infos
dessus
je dirais de la vie courante des
activités l'on vient de voir les
inscriptions pour le sport tout ça c'est
vraiment le cot est utile
laurent duthil d'autres initiatives sont
déjà bien ancré dans la maison d'arrêt
comme l'émission de radio fréquence
taulard que l'on peut retrouver sur
thème radio ont créé une émission de
radio donc la première on a un premier
rendez vous on a vraiment élaboré
différents sujets qu'on pouvait aborder
en maison d'arrêt parce que c'est pas
toujours évident ne peuvent pas sortir
pour aller faire des interviews on
enregistre les questions et après c'est
moi donc qui vais poser les questions
aux différents intervenants même idée
pour la gazette du taulard un journal de
détention créé par les détenus pour les
détenus qui fête sa première année avec
son dixième numéro un tiers de la
population carcérale serait illettrés
cette multitude d'activités vient
valoriser les détenus et leur permet de
travailler des compétences multiples
voilà sans transition dans ce journal
intéressons nous à présent à une
solution séduisante pour faire face à la
flambée des prix d'énergie
l'autosuffisance énergétique
c'est la solution choisie par une
entreprise de la sarthe grâce à
l'installation d'un panneau solaire
géant à la clé des économies
d'électricité et une facture allégée
explication d'un zoo maubert pour lm tv
sortent regarder
ici on l'appelle le tracker un panneau
solaire géant bourré technologie capable
de fournir toute l'énergie dont cette
entreprise a besoin il permet de
travailler sur deux plans donc de suivre
le soleil le matin jusqu'au soir et 2000
et double-face également ce qui lui
permet de récupérer l'énergie de saint
face exposée au soleil mais aussi de sa
phase compte et rieur ça nous permet
surtout aujourd'hui en cas de forte
présence du soleil de produire plus
d'électricité que demander et 2
mais pressé d'électricité quand un
coffre fort énergétique le panneau
embarque aussi des outils de suivi en
temps réel pour savoir où quand et
comment est utilisé l'électricité en
consommer l'électricité compenser juste
mais finalement avec le suivi internet
on s'aperçoit que ont consommé ont
gaspillé beaucoup d'électricité
notamment la nuit ou des appareils
restés tournés compenser sans grand
impact on va dire électrique mais qui
finalement quand les couples on
économise pour l'entreprise qui embauche
80 salariés cette démarche s'inscrit
dans une volonté globale de réduire son
impact environnemental
alors qu'elle est en plein développement
on a fait appel à des spécialistes donc
le cpe qui eux sont venus faire un état
des lieux
du quartier entre guillemets pour savoir
quelles sont les espèces présentes ici
et savoir si on peut pas améliorer entre
guillemets leur cadre de vie à l'avenir
et si jamais on a besoin d'extension de
ne pas les perturber
l'entreprise espère désormais aller plus
loin elle prévoit de réinjecter les
économies effectuées dans la recherche
et le développement écologique de son
activité
qui sait elle verra peut-être même
éclore une véritable réserve naturelle
sur son site
donne aussi pour l'environnement la
consigne des bouteilles de verre est
elle en train de faire son grand retour
en france pour limiter le poids des
déchets les collectivités ont décidé de
récompenser le tri du verre le principe
est simple chaque bouteille déposé dans
un conteneur rapporte des points
échangeables ensuite contre des bons
d'achat dans l'agglomération de roanne
300 conteneurs connectés ont été
installés et plus de 9000 personnes sont
déjà inscrites au dispositif reportage
et explications de christophe rigaud sur
place
noémie et sa fille marie ont leurs
petites habitudes
régulièrement dans ces grands sacs elle
récupère tous les récipients en verre
bocaux bouteille de sirop
et même les petits pots de yaourt aussi
puis la madame tri de la famille en fait
je récupère tout le vert et je leur
porte aux containers une fois de temps
en temps si noémie est motivé pour
collecter les bouteilles de verre c'est
que depuis neuf mois l'agglomération de
roy une récompense ce geste de tri grâce
à ces bornes connectés chaque contenant
verts déposés rapporte des points sur le
smartphone de noémie des points quelques
convertir en dons à des associations ou
aux bons d'achat auprès de commerçants
locaux sans qu'on a delà de la réduction
sur l'alimentaire sur des produits
d'hygiène sur un coiffeur sur une
boutique de deux livres etc on à 5% 10%
20% un café un muffin un shampoing
offert avec l'époque un petit geste qui
est bon pour le pouvoir d'achat mais
surtout pour l'écologie c'est ce qui a
séduit ces deux étudiants si on voit
tous les rapports qui tombe et c'est
important de changer et de badauds
recyclé notamment de changer par le
recycler parce que ça reste un geste
assez simple à faire dans mon quotidien
voire recyclés et gagner quelque chose
en retour ses rangs que ce simple et
efficace on peut le faire avec
application avec la carte sport m
grâce aux fonds accumulés on peut par
exemple se rendre dans ce commerce de
produits ménagers en vrac pour profiter
de réductions une boutique qui encourage
aussi le recyclage ça rentre dans le
même cadre que notre concept de la
réduction des déchets donc ça semblait
logique pour nous de participer à cette
ce concept là de se dire d'un on utilise
nos bouteilles de verre pour les mettre
pour bien aller les recycler pour
vraiment faire ce geste là de se
déplacer au container pour recycler les
bouteilles de verre pour le maire de
roanne et président de l'agglomération
le bilan est déjà largement positif
c'est donc 11% et les chiffres
progressent encore de collecte de verre
supplémentaires et par conséquent donc
c'est pour nous donc un succès c'est
aussi un bilan en terme de propreté
puisque nous avons beaucoup moins de
deux verres qui sont déposés quasiment
plus d'ailleurs au pied des conteneurs
donc que volontaire jette un
investissement certes pour la
collectivité paie par contre les âmes
l'amortissement du dispositif se fait
sur à peine deux ans depuis son
lancement en octobre 2021 dans
l'agglomération rouennaise 2 millions
700 mille bouteilles de verre ont pu
être récupérées
en corse la protection de
l'environnement passe par la
sensibilisation des plus jeunes sur
l'île de beauté 70 élèves viennent donc
de participer à l'éco lanta des épreuves
et des énigmes autour de la gestion de
l'eau potable
une manière ludique d'éduquer aux enjeux
climatiques en s'inspirant du célèbre
jeu d'aventuré images et propos
recueillis par angel ricciardi de la
rédaction devient telle est pas aisé
l'idée c'est vraiment d'apprendre les
bons gestes pour utiliser correctement
l'eau et surtout la protéger on explique
du coup ben toutes les actions que l'on
peut faire pour ne pas la polluer pour
ne pas la gaspiller mais on explique
aussi surtout l'eau virtuelle l'eau
cachée celle qui est d'en utiliser pour
notre alimentation nos vêtements dans
votre caméra dans nos téléviseurs
quand l'art vient au secours de la
biodiversité l'artiste monégasque
philippe pastor très engagé pour la
préservation de l'environnement expose
actuellement l'une de ses oeuvres dans
le très beau village de saint paul de
vence les arbres brûlés c'est son nom
son objectif alerter sur la fragilité de
la nature depuis 20 ans et les graves
incendies survenus à l'été 2003 dans la
région ses sculptures de troncs d'arbres
calcinés ont pour habitude d'être
exposées un peu partout dans le monde
écoutez à ce propos philippe pastor
interrogé par stéphane attia et qu'elle
est une garce ya
principal souci c'était de bon de faire
des sculptures pour montrer aux gens que
le feu ça existait parce qu'à l'époque
le changement dit crise climatique et
est encore léger et à l'époque
on se pensait pas que c'était le climat
qui pouvait nous amener des incendies on
pensait pas que la chaleur pouvait nous
apporter ceci cela j'essaye de l'est de
les mettre dans des endroits où
effectivement les touristes peut-être
pas les gens du pays mais les touristes
qui des fois seront pas compte que la
nature est aussi sèche est aussi prête à
démarrer les incendies peuvent partir
aussi vite
je j'ai essayé en tout cas de mon côté
de faire ce qu'il fallait pour pour
montrer que le feu existe
voilà et si vous êtes curieux de
découvrir le travail de philippe pastor
sachez que certaines de ses oeuvres sont
actuellement exposées à saint raphaël et
à nice sur la côte d'azur bien sûr
direction la loi dans ce journal et plus
précisément une commune qui vient d'être
élue plus beau village du département
par les journaux du dauphiné et du
progrès dans ce village de caractère les
passionnés d'art flâne dans les
quartiers des artistes et faire une
histoire le admire les bâtiments moyen
âgeux et pour les gourmands des biscuits
conçu sur place commence à se faire un
nom visite guidée avec adrien bletterie
de tl7 la télévision de la loi
marolles et sa place de la fontaine et
ses ruelles pavées qui mène à l'église
romane construit au septième siècle et
son architecture qui lui donne du
caractère un village totalement atypique
pour un emplacement sur le versant
sud-est des monts du forez avec une vue
magnifique sur toute la plaine les monts
du lyonnais par beau temps on voit le
mont blanc donc la situation
géographique est vraiment assez
exceptionnel tous ces éléments font
qu'il ya une vie touristique qui est
très intéressante et qu'on essaye de
dynamiser par l'ajout de spectacles de
concerts et d'expositions
ce village de 450 habitants n'arrête pas
d'être animée l'hiver c'est le marché de
noël qui attire plus de 5000 visiteurs
l'été ces moissons de culture qui
propose des concerts du cinéma des
randonnées et des expositions car depuis
dix ans il y à un village dans le
village celui des artistes est très dur
pour moi au début mais maintenant je
pense que j'arrive un peu mieux à parler
de mon travail et il ya des moments
c'est même très émouvant en fait de
d'échanger avec les avec les personnes
que j'ai été reçu par les artistes de
marolles d'une façon extraordinaire donc
j'ai eu envie de paille habité et
d'avoir ma boutique sur marolles il ya
cinq artistes qui sont résidents à
l'année à marolles l'été il y en a trois
fois plus avec des installations en
extérieur les touristes viennent en
nombre pour admirer les oeuvres mais ce
n'est pas tout du côté de la pause marot
l'aise et des biscuits font aussi la pub
du village il ya toujours un petit
encart qui parle de marolles surtout nos
sachets et qui disent tiens on va aller
visiter le village et ils reviennent ici
voilà marolles attire plus de dix mille
visiteurs par an le tourisme est
primordial pour faire vivre le village
un village et qui souhaite que les
futures générations soit tout aussi
impliqués que les précédentes ça veut
dire que les enfants seront fiers d'un
quand ils auront 20 à 30 ans de venir à
marolles de rester à marolles et de
hêtres passer le relais voilà je crois
que c'est ça l'idée aussi pour l'instant
ça promet les enfants de l'école ont
déjà lancé un projet un jeu de pistes
numériques avec loire story il faut
aider les artistes à retrouver leurs
couleurs
je vous le disais dans les titres de ce
journal tom benoît sera en duplex dans
quelques instants pour nous parler de
son nouvel ouvrage aphorismes sur l'
architecture mais avant cela le
philosophe et essayiste spécialiste de
l'architecturé de l'urbanisme prépare
pour la rentrée une série d'émissions de
philosophie sur tv5monde des premiers
tournages ont eu lieu au musée guimet à
paris avec l'architecte jean nouvel
traire à la télévision regardez un
extrait en avant-première de leur
entretien la première chose qu'il
faudrait faire
c'est s'est créé la loi sur le littoral
vers j'appelle seule lio de loi littoral
vers cris qui reprendrait la loi sur le
littoral la loi littoral et et qui
ferait en sorte qu on déterminerait une
limite de l'étalement urbain et que tout
le reste est strictement
inconstructibles sauf pour les valeurs
qu'ils sont
agricoles ou
exagérées s'élançait donc mais ce qu'ils
font qu'il ya un pouvoir solidariste
pour ainsi dire au sens de les
hambourgeois beaucoup de pouvoir social
libéral pour les entrepreneurs que sont
les architectes les architectes doivent
avoir davantage de pouvoirs à l'heure
actuelle non on ne peut pas être un peut
pas imaginer un livre sans auteur ne
peut pas imaginer une composition de
musique sans auteur ne peut pas imaginer
une ville est un lieu où on va vivre
sans quelqu'un qui le conçoit et nous
avons donc le plaisir d'être en duplex
avec vous comme benoît bonjour
aphorismes sur l' architecture vient de
paraître chez nba e édition qu'est ce
qui vous a incité à écrire ce livre
alors tout d'abord une volonté la
palombe et la matière mais c'est un
ultra dictée c'est l'éditeur donc la 2e
édition qui est tombé amoureux du livre
pour ainsi dire qui a insisté pour faire
paraître cet ouvrage aussi rapidement
c'est un livre il ya déjà plusieurs mois
plusieurs années
tom benoît dites nous quel était votre
état d'esprit lors de l'écriture de ce
livre
j'essaie la forêt de sur architecture
tout d'abord avec une certaine idée une
violence c'est avait un aspect sauvage
politique et littéraire parce que
sauvage d'abord par rapport à vos
formats les aphorismes quelque chose de
créer direct lorsqu'on écrit des
aphorismes et donc pour vous de
l'accessibilité pour le lecteur et la
volonté de faire appréhender
larchitecture par le prisme de la
matière l'usure du vieillissement de
tout ce qui constitue l' architecture
quels sont vos projets en matière
d'écriture tom benoît quels sont vos
objectifs en matière d'agriculture et en
général avoir une action politique julie
est détourné et essayer d'apporter sur
le plan urbanistique par la réflexion
aux relations ce que je n'aurais
peut-être à pas le talent d'apporter à
la philosophie parce que tout a dit je
pense qu'on doit aujourd'hui adapter la
philosophie aux problématiques modernes
donc aux problématiques de ville aux
problématiques de santé publique de
gestion de la santé collective aux
problématiques urbanistique
faits visés pas forcément problématique
mais au questionnement urbanistique et
de santé publique voilà merci tome
benoît d'avoir été l'invitée du grand jt
des territoires en duplex je rappelle
que votre livre aphorismes sur
l'architecturé disponible chez nba e
édition tout à fait autre chose c'est
une première historique et mondial des
lycéens martinique et viennent de
traverser la manche à bord d'une yole
ronde une embarcation typique de la
martinique un défi et un exploit relevé
en 3 heures 30 pour un parcours de 40 km
une performance donc que vous découvrez
sur ces images de nos partenaires
devient atv et qui permet de mettre en
valeur cette pratique la yole ronde est
inscrite au patrimoine immatériel de
l'unesco depuis deux ans bravo à eux
pour ce défi relevé avec courage et
détermination bien sûr de la manche à la
vienne dans cette édition restons sur
l'eau à limoges un jeu de piste ludique
permet de découvrir l'histoire du bois
flotté ce bois qui a permis
historiquement l'approvisionnement de la
ville lors de son développement une
manière pratique et pédagogique de
remonter au début du 19e siècle et d'en
savoir un peu plus sur l'usagé du bois
cette époque précision au micro d'adrien
de 7 à limoges sur place dans le cadre
d'un projet collectif de recherche on a
travaillé sur l'approvisionnement en
bois de la ville de limoges et on s'est
penché sur le bois qui arrivait par la
vienne et qu'arrivé au flottage par
flottage en octobre 1814 et c'est pierre
darne et qui va vous faire découvrir sa
journée de travail de marchands de bois
à aller acheter son bois le faire venir
jusqu'à limoges le stocker et on va
découvrir toute cette histoire allait
referme ce journal sur un sujet qui sent
bon l'été des glaces vous en dégusterez
c'est sûr pendant toutes ses vacances à
côté des classiques industriels les
glaces artisanales gagne du terrain dans
les vosges une ferme locale propose
notamment aux enfants de fabriquer leur
propre glace en bâtonnets une
illustration supplémentaire du désir des
producteurs de transformer et de vendre
toute une partie de leur production un
reportage bio et gourmand de ludovic
biya et de denis le kent pour vosges
télévision
pour les enfants qui c'est qui va
prendre un pot pour aller faire son
bateau n'ait aucune difficulté à trouver
des volontaires pour cet atelier la
fabrication de sa propre glace en
bâtonnets emilien s'est fait avec quoi
une glace
maxence qui se cale dans une glace ben
juillet
fanny produit des glaces artisanales
depuis deux ans une activité
complémentaire au premier métier du
foyer la production de lait bio par 45
vaches et la clientèle à d'emblée été au
rendez vous six mille litres de lait
transformé la première année pour un
chiffre d'affaires de près de 50000
euros soit un huitième de celui de
l'exploitation agricole c'est loin
d'être négligeable
une nouvelle illustration que la
transformation sur place et la vente
directe est synonyme de vraie plus value
je fais ma crainte
maintenant je fais mes yaourts que
j'incorpore dans les glaces au yaourt
après on ajoute nos sucre parfum moi je
vais pas de pas d'armes pas de colorant
c'est des vrais doutes de vanille cédé
au frais une fabrication qui prend du
temps exemple avec la vanille d'autant
que les boues sur 24 dans fusion de dans
le résultat des saveurs incomparables
quant au prix et à qualité égale il est
quasi similaire aux produits industriels
vendus en grande surface comptez 12
euros le litre
pad embauche pour l'heure c'est encore
trop tôt cette animation avait lieu dans
le cadre des journées nationales de
l'agriculture mais l'exploitation étant
également labellisé bienvenue à la ferme
l accueil du public une grande partie de
l'année notamment en partenariat avec
l'office de tourisme de neufchâteau
voilà qui donne envie à quelques jours
des vacances c'est la fin de ce grand jt
des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]